[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 et 12 spéciales championnat de france
par équipes de gymnastique le sommaire
de l'émission
focus sur les championnats de france de
gymnastique tous les détails sur ces
trois jours de compétition au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
nous rencontrerons des organisateurs
ainsi que les sportifs de la gemme
elancourt mort pas présents sur cet
événement le résumé la semaine coûte
projecteurs notamment sur la journée de
sensibilisation handisport au lycée
dumont de maurepas zoom également sur
les exploitants yves binois présent au
festival de cannes avant de rejoindre
l'une des organisatrices ici au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines coup de
projecteur sur le latmos laboratoire
fêter ses dix ans un reportage des
satellites des prototypes de rover le
laboratoire l'atmo spécialisé dans
l'observation spatiale et de
l'atmosphère fêtait ce jeudi 23 mai à
guyancourt ses 10 ans avec ses
partenaires
l'occasion de montrer les travaux
réalisés sur le site depuis ses débuts
ça représente aujourd'hui 10 missions
spatiales qui tourne autour de la terre
ou qui sont partis explorer le système
solaire et dans lequel le laboratoire où
était à l'origine du concept ou créer un
instrument ou est en charge de l'analyse
opérationnelle des données parmi les
projets réalisés certains chercheurs
installés sur le site on travaillait sur
un satellite baptisé mars express
l'appareil collecte en ce moment des
données sur l'atmosphère de la planète
rouge
le satellite est en orbite autour de
mars et puis il se met à regarder une
étoile dans la nuit et cette étoile il
va l'avoir tout doucement descendre
derrière l'horizon et le spectre que
l'on enregistre de cette étoile est en
fait modulée par la présence des
composants gazeuse dans l'atmosphère de
mars donc on est capable de déduire la
température la quantité d'ozone la
quantité de dioxyde de carbone qui est
le composé principal de l'atmosphère
cette journée permettait également de
montrer les futurs projets qui vont
animer le centre sur les prochaines
années
en 2020 ce cube va être lâché dans
l'espace a pris moins de trois ans
d'existence
son objectif mesurer les flux solaire
entre le soleil et la terre
à toutes les composantes d'un satellite
mais miniaturisés donc on va retrouver
des fonctions classiques un ordinateur
de bord qui permet de faire la
communication entre les différentes
cartes du satellite
on va avoir une carte de communication
qui va permettre la communication entre
les éléments du satellite est le seul
avec des antennes et ensuite la dernière
partie donc on va y est associée une
charge utile donc des instruments
scientifiques qui vont pouvoir faire les
mesures pour le grand public d'autres
événements seront organisés tout au long
de l'année dans la structure le latmos
ouvrira notamment ses portes le 21
septembre prochain pour les journées du
patrimoine
et je suis maintenant avec morgane
dollars l'une des organisatrice de cet
événement morgan comment ça se passe là
les athètes viennent d'arriver le public
également comment ça se passe a commencé
vers 8h30 pour les premiers athlètes
donc assez tôt on a le les premières
personnes du public commence à arriver
et on a également les classes de
scolaires qui viennent d'arriver
voilà c'est vendredi donc forcément il
ya un petit peu moins de monde que les
autres jours les gens travaillent à
principalement les proches des athlètes
mais voilà ça commence doucement à se
remplir mais ça va ça se passe comme
prévu pour l'instant ça se passe comme
prévu avec tous les aléas d'un événement
pas fait qui peut y avoir
mais on arrive à gérer ça on a une super
équipe de bénévoles oui ça se passe bien
au niveau de la compétition qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve ce matin ici sur les
tapis alors ce matin à la division
nationale 2 et la division nationale 5
qui sont sur le plateau donc sachant que
la une est la meilleure et l'a6 est un
peu moins bonne donc pour vous situer un
petit peu et donc on a des garçons et
des filles qui match
toute la journée sur ce plateau donc si
je comprends bien ce sont des athlètes
qui viennent de toute la france
vraiment exactement on a des gens qui
viennent de toute la france des dom
tonnes
la corse de toute la france de dunkerque
à marseille on a déjà fait qu'ils
viennent de partout c'est un peu plus
difficile pour les dom-tom parce qu'ils
ont tout ce qui est décalage horaire
mais mais voilà on a des athlètes de
toute la france le niveau est bon le
niveau est plutôt très bon d'années
après année on améliore le niveau de la
gymnastique le matériel de gym nova fait
aussi que voilà le matériel s'améliore
on peut améliorer nos performances faire
des difficultés encore plus
impressionnante
et voilà le niveau est de plus en plus
bon au niveau du public est-ce qu'il
faut être spécialiste pour revenir sur
cet événement non on n'a pas besoin
d'être spécialiste en plus on à la
société fb cup qui est là pour faire des
petites démonstrations avec des vidéos
justement pour expliquer aux novices
comment fonctionne la gymnastique les
figures et c'est donc vraiment y'a aucun
souci on peut venir la mission des
novices il y aura du spectacle c'est
impressionnant ces acrobaties and
artistic voilà il ya tout sur un plateau
justement comment ça se passe les
athlètes passent par vraiment où les
agresser ça voilà donc les jeunes filles
sont sur quatre agrès saut barres poutre
et sol est l'exact les garçons pardon
son sursis zagré arts sont parallèles
fixe le cheval sol et anneaux on a
oublié
et donc voilà on les et tout le monde
passe surtout les agréent en tout cas
toutes les équipes le permet de l'équipe
chez les féminines par exemple ces cinq
gymnastes dans une équipe
les quatre meilleurs à la grée passe et
les trois meilleures notes sont
comptabilisés pour faire lé tout et je
précise que c'est une première en ile de
france depuis 20 ans chez évolution
ouais ça fait vingt ans que ça s'est pas
fait en ile de france la dernière fois
il me semble que c'était dans le 95
beaucoup première fois en tout cas sur
saint quentin en yvelines
depuis toujours donc c'est une petite
pression supplémentaire pour nous mais
une petite fierté aussi parce que on est
les premiers à avoir re passer le pas et
avoir accepté ce challenge est donc on
est plutôt très content et en tout cas
ça part bien pour le week-end et vous
espérez justement attirer les gens de 50
ans divine et les personnes de saint
quentin en yvelines
tout à fait les personnes de saint
quentin en yvelines mais même les
personnes de toute l'île de france on a
un vivier énorme deux clubs en ile de
france on a une centaine de clubs toutes
fédérations confondues et on espère que
ben ils se sentiront tous concernés et
qui profiteront de cette opportunité
pour venir voir de la gymnastique
parce que en gros en gymnastique sur en
région parisienne mais on a un gars que
deux gros événements c'est les
championnats de france et les
internationaux de france qui ont lieu à
version à septembre
donc voilà on espère qu'ils nous
rejoignent tout le week-end
parmi les personnes de 50 ans ni ville
on les voit juste derrière nous les
scolaires
c'est ça les scolaires ont été mis sur
ce projet on était on peut dire associés
associé au projet tout à fait on a
invité à peu près 600 scolaires sur
cette journée principalement des écoles
primaires de saint quentin en yvelines
on a un collège qui est le collège de la
clé saint pierre qui est là ça peut
susciter les vocations pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas ça peut susciter des
vocations ou pas d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est un peu ce qu'on espère aussi faire
découvrir la gymnastique qui est quand
même assez peu médiatisé en france et je
pense que oui si ça peut faire naître
des vocations ce sera super et en plus
on a pas mal de clubs sur saint quentin
en yvelines de gymnastique donc voilà
justement parmi ces clubs il ya là
j'aime elancourt maurepas le club phare
on peut le dire de des yvelines c'est
gentil
est-ce que ce c'est peut-être ses futurs
jeunes viendront dans votre club un jour
et à ce qu'on peut les accueillir
nous oui on peut les accueillir et on
les accueillera avec plaisir maintenant
il ya les clubs de guyancourt villepreux
les clés
voisin ya pas mal de clubs malgré tout
qu'ils sont aux alentours donc ça dépend
souvent du lieu d'habitation nous c'est
vrai qu' on est un club assez important
et d'ailleurs on commence à arriver un
peu à un niveau de mai on a pas mal
d'adhérents on a pas mal d'entraîneurs
mais on manque de salles d'horaires de
créneaux et c'est donc on arrive un peu
à un point où on a envie de s'agrandir
en tant que club mais on n'a pas encore
les infrastructures municipales qui le
permettent donc peut-être que cet
événement va vous aider peut-être que
cet événement voilà mettra en lumière un
petit peu le club aussi et nous
permettra peut-être d'avoir un peu plus
de moyens on va dire pour monter le club
et parmi ces jeunes du coup que vous
avez au club est-ce qu'il y en a
certains qui vont match et du coup oui
il ya trois équipes du club qui vont
match et donc il y a une équipe en
division nationale si ce sont des
féminines une équipe en division
nationale 4 des féminines aussi et on a
notre meilleure équipe qui en division 1
nationale une qui match sera également
donc samedi soir et pour les deux autres
équipes c'est pour le dimanche justement
on va regarder le portrait de trois
d'entre elles qui sont au club de la
gêne et là encore maurepas sont revenus
tout les trois médaillés des
championnats de france individuels le 12
mai dernier à nice 17 ans et lee et
hyaline 14 ans sont trois gymnastes
yvelinoise formé à la gemme elancourt
mort pas un club qui les a vu éclore des
filles qui ont beaucoup de talent
on essaye dans la mesure du possible de
développer encore plus ses talents mais
pour faire ce qu'elles font il ya il ya
des qualités innées même avec du travail
on pas les avoir ça fait là presque 20
ans que j'entraîne
j'ai vu passer pas mal de gymnastes et
des gymnastes avec autant de talent
aussi bien physique que mental
elle a pas beaucoup pour continuer à
progresser les trois pépites qui sont au
club depuis plusieurs saisons
s'entraînent entre 12 et 20 heures par
semaine sur ces à gré aux gymnases du
bois mort pas et tout cela dans un
esprit familial la politique du club
je pense que ça joue parce que quand
quelqu'un en fin de compte par exemple
savamment bien sûr une séance à ce qu'on
là pour me motiver ou m'encourager
moi pareil c'est le sera pas dans celle
ci on se retrouve avec des filles qui
n'aiment pas va enfin maman envie de
s'entraîner du coup après grassement
un esprit familial qui est associé à
l'exigence du haut niveau objectif pour
les coaches repousser toujours plus
leurs limites délit au niveau l'action
des hanches haut niveau l'action des
épaules c'est encore plus petits elles
peuvent encore faire mieux
peuvent durcir les mouvements faire des
mouvements on va dire plus compliqué
plus long plus propres au site c'est une
des qualités de la gymnastique c'est le
premier artistique donc il faut de
l'exécution parfaite si on va voir des
bonnes notes et donc des médailles
prochain rendez vous pour ces pépites
les championnats de france par équipes
qui seront organisées du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les trois amis ont à coeur de remporter
des titres devant leur public et il n'y
aura pas que ses trois pépites qui
seront ici au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines a pour ces
championnats de france il y aura
également camille et marie qui font
partie de la gemme elancourt mort pas
comment on gère cet événement bears et
événements avec beaucoup de stress car
l'organisation c'était vraiment à
quelque chose qui était grand et au
final comme on peut voir là ça s'est
très bien passé
tout se passe très bien alors on est
encore plus enjoué est chez nous que
c'est notre public et en plus de ça
voilà nous match demain et on est très
contente d'être ici chose pour vous
marie oui c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
de stress parce que l'organisation ça a
été compliqué à gérer il ya énormément
de choses à faire mais c'est encore plus
excitant parce qu'on aura notre public
avec nous d'ailleurs faut venir nombreux
nous encourager il y aura la famille les
amis tout ça ça va être génial
justement qu'est ce que ça change
vraiment pour des athlètes de jouer à
domicile c'est sûr qu'on aura en tout
notre public
cette fois-ci vraiment tout le monde
pourra venir nous voir et puis quand il
ya le public comme ça ça nous porte nous
donne des ailes et souvent passer de
l'émotion
c'est encore mieux sur les agrès pas
qu'est ce que ça représente tout
simplement de jouer à domicile devant
son public devant autant de monde
ben moi les compétitions elle a une
saveur différente maintenant c'est comme
une routine de venir aux championnats de
france c'est plutôt une passation on va
dire parce que là on commençait à
concourir avec les plus jeunes
c'est en fait on est un peu les mamans
du groupe c on est les deux plus
vieilles et on leur apporte le calme les
derniers conseils techniques je pense
que c'est important d'être là pour elle
aussi et nous c'est que du plaisir
maintenant c'est vraiment on va
s'éclater quoi est ce que vous pensez
remporter une médaille alors nous ont
bien sûr on espère forcément augmenter
de médailles comme dans tout le
championnat de france
mais l'objectif premier pour nous c'est
surtout voilà 2 2 qui fait notre compet
de s'amuser de s'éclater de se faire
plaisir surtout plus importants et
ensuite on espère aussi un maintien en
dn1 parce que voilà c'est important de
pouvoir se maintenir tout ensemble et
pas forcément pourquoi pas une petite
médaille à la clé justement d alain
c'est quoi c'est le meilleur niveau on
va dire ici c'est meilleur niveau qui
représentait ce week end voilà on va
dire que c'est un peu comme la ligue 2
du football c'est le meilleur niveau du
week end où ce concours les 12
meilleures équipes du week end ça se
prépare combien de temps à l'avancé une
compétition comme celle là c'est toute
l'année quand on arrive en septembre on
a déjà ça en tête c'est une présente
préparation de longue haleine c'est de
la muscu de la paix vraie préparation
physique puis dans le mental c'est bien
de faire quelques compétitions avant
donc on sait que les compétitions
durant toute l'année c'est pour préparer
aujourd'hui c'est la finale c'est
aujourd'hui donc ça se prépare toute
l'année ils médaille pour vous aussi
on espère toujours c'est le petit bonus
c'est ce qui fait briller les yeux
est-ce que vous avez un petit dernier
message à passer aux téléspectateurs de
télé 78 bien sûr venez nombreux nous
encourager voilà on attend beaucoup de
public
on espère que l'ile-de-france va nous
porter et que ça va nous porte nous
aider justement pourquoi pas avant une
petite médaille
merci beaucoup et maintenant on va du
côté des tribunes de ce vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis à côté à des scolaires qui sont
venus spécialement aujourd'hui pour voir
la compétition à mes côtés elisa et lisa
qui vient de monter bretonneux et lisa
s'est contenté souci ah oui bennett fois
au championnat de la ficr a impressionné
tous les atouts qui font moins ça me
donne des idées
est ce que ça donne envie
justement d'être gymnastes oui un peu
j'en fais déjà un peu de la gym mais pas
autant comme ça qu'est ce qui t'a
impressionne le plus marco grassi a
également loué à mes côtés loup qu'est
ce que t'en penses quoi
bah j'aime bien c'est beau il j'aime
bien les personnes diplômées saito c'est
impressionnant
une première pour toi tu fais la
gymnastique ou pas j'en fais pas ça
donne envie d'en faire parce que je fais
un autre sport et j'ai passé un médecin
belge mais en tout cas tu passe un bon
moment ici un très bon moment
il y a plusieurs centaines de personnes
ici et on va les entendre justement est
ce que vous pouvez faire du bruit
[Applaudissements]
on quitte maintenant ce blood national
de saint quentin en yvelines pour le
résumé de la semaine c'est parti
[Musique]
après trois ans de travaux voici les
nouveaux bâtiments de santé mentale de
l'institut mgen de la verrière
opérationnel depuis un mois près de 200
adolescents jeunes adultes et adultes y
sont accueillis sur ce même site de 12
hectares un ehpad ou encore une unité de
soins palliatifs verront le jour début
2000 vingt deux établissements
historiques sont regroupés le centre de
santé mentale marcel rivière et le
centre gériatrique et denis forestier on
a souhaité tout regrouper sur un même
site pour pouvoir aussi avoir une prise
en charge dans le même esprit un peu
l'esprit village c'est à dire que tous
les tous les services se travaille
ensemble également et avec avec une
prise en charge la plus optimisée pour
nos patients à nos résidents tout paul
confondues l'institut mgen propose 4 185
lits soit 20% de plus qu'avant il s'agit
du site le plus important en france en
termes de capacité d'accueil
les patients qui viennent ici sont
adressés par les professionnels de santé
du territoire
80 % ne sont pas mutualistes c'est une
réponse pour la population de proximité
la population des yvelines mais aussi
d'île de france
la particularité du côté du projet santé
mentale c'est que toutes les unités sont
18es ressources spécialisées pour les
autres secteurs pour les collègues qui
travaillent sur le territoire
nous sommes spécialisés dans la
psychiatrie la personne âgée dans la
psychiatrie de l'adolescent et du jeune
adulte dans la mythologie ou dans la
post urgence par exemple vue sur le
château de la verrière ou encore jardin
protégé permettent un meilleur cadre de
vie aux patients en tout 35 mille mètres
carrés ont été reconstruits
investissements pour ce projet médical
100 millions d'euros
[Musique]
même si le geste est un peu hésitant les
élèves du lycée dumont-d'urville de
maurepas ont pu tout au long de la
matinée se mettre dans la peau de
personnes en situation de handicap pour
pratiquer le vélo qui sont très investis
il alterne bien les différents ateliers
ça leur permet aussi de découvrir bas
différentes disciplines
concernant leurs 10 sport cette
manifestation a été mise en place par
les élèves de la mention complémentaire
animation et gestion de projets dans le
secteur sportif
le handisport un thème qui a fait
l'unanimité au sein de la classe ce
qu'on trouve que c'est pas assez
développée en france ou même à
l'étranger que que les personnes en
difficulté ont vraiment besoin dead ou
même de deux subventions servent en
emportant en fait parmi les intervenants
le vc e sky
le vélo club basé à elancourt a ouvert
en 2013 une section handisport et compte
douze licenciés moi c'est important de
montrer qu'on peut être handicapé et
continue à faire du sport et quand sa
part a montré du doigt et faire voir que
on peut faire tout ce qu'on veut en
fauteuil on leur explique qu'on continue
à faire du sport la musculation
au quotidien nous entretenir et le vélo
c'est d'évasion au programme également
de cette journée de sensibilisation des
rencontres l'après midi avec des
athlètes paralympiques
[Musique]
des textes pensée est couché sur le
papier en 2015 il n'y a pas de lait qu'a
voulu transmettre ses pensées ses
émotions sur les événements tragiques
parisien j'ai pas écrit ce recueil pour
un public spécifique mais c'est vrai que
je pensais c'était un petit peu
difficile pour un public collégiens et
ils ont choisi sansan de connaître en
fait pour ça que c'est encore vraiment
plus plus important puisque justement
ils ne me connaissent pas et c'est
vraiment le texte qu'ils ont choisie
pour ce prix lydia pas de lait qui était
face à trois autres ouvrages avec un
jury inédit 350 collégiens saint
quentinois
tout d'abord d'arrêter que la couverture
et on a classé enfants d'affaires
classement provisoire des livres qu'on
avait le plus insolite entamée le mois
qu'après on à entrer dans le vif du
sujet on a regardé vraiment ce qu'ils
avaient dans le livre c'était sympa de
faire appel à des collégiens pour fort à
la poésie parce que souvent balles et
les jeunes et baena puisse pas vraiment
la poésie et faire appel à des jeunes
mais c'est quand même assez original on
en apprend beaucoup des du poète fin
franchement c'est génial oui moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé comme ça j'ai découvert la
poète et beaucoup de livres le prix
collégiens lecteurs de poésie
d'aujourd'hui existe depuis trois ans
piloté par les itinéraires poétique
qu'il vise à diffuser la poésie
contemporaine
les ouvrages ont tous été édité
récemment fait un choix dans tout ce
qu'on reçoit ce ne sont pas des livres
destinés à la jeunesse c'est ça c'est
voulu et enfin choix qui permettent de
montrer une l'éclectisme delà de la
création poétique mais aussi les
critiques de l'édition politique à
travers des ouvrages de forme va dire de
toucher différents aussi un travail
réalisé en cours ou lors d'ateliers les
collégiens ont aussi réalisé des vidéos
autour des textes étudiés 14 classes ont
participé à cette troisième édition
[Musique]
douze ans qu'ils viennent au festival de
cannes leur première c'était ensemble
cette année encore gaëlle pineau élue
beaucamp sont venus à deux pour une
semaine de cinéma
un moment qui compte pour eux une bulle
d'oxygène dans leur quotidien
d'exploitants de salles
en tant que voisin on travaille
régulièrement ensemble on discute
beaucoup et de venir ici c'est on a les
mêmes informations en même temps on
prend du temps aussi ensemble on mange
ensemble régulièrement order ensemble
pas dans le même lit mais dans le même
appartement
non mais c'est un moment de convivialité
aussi pour nous qui est vachement
important dans une année de travail
au programme de la semaine rencontres et
réunions avec les autres responsables
des cinémas art et essai et beaucoup de
films aussi pour assister à des
projections accessible grâce à une
accréditation et des invitations avec en
moyenne 1h30 d'attentes devant les
salles pendant toute l'année on regarde
pas autant le film que ça pourtant on
est programmateur donc beaucoup
connaissent un maximum donc là on fait
le plein le plein le plein de films pour
ce 72e festival luc et gaëlle ont vu une
vingtaine de films de la sélection
officielle à la semaine de la critique
trois ont particulièrement retenu leur
attention cette année on en parle on a
un peu les mêmes coups de coeur ah c'est
vrai qu'il ya papicha un film qui se
passe en algérie pendant les années 90
on a beaucoup aimé ce film là et c'est
sûr que attrape israël sera projeté il
ya aussi et aussi les misérables de la
ssii
et puis aussi un très beau film
d'animation qui s'appelle j'ai perdu mon
corps qui à mon avis sera primé parce
que magnifique superbe film qu'on a vu
des coups de coeur que l'on devrait
retrouver dans les salles du ciné 7 et
du grenier à sel dans les prochains mois
[Musique]
elles font 35 cm et honte avec des
moteurs de chevaux ces petites voitures
radiocommandées ils sont très équipée
elle concourt tu as une compétition
régionale
c'est une course 80 pilotes et ça va se
dérouler sur la journée ça a commencé ce
matin à 8 heures jusqu'à 18h ce soir
ce matin c'est les qualifications et
dans l'après midi on va faire les
remontées jusqu'à la finale qui aura
lieu vers 17h30 18h le club de modélisme
de maurepas va fêter cette année ses 50
ans cent trente adhérents le composent
sur trois catégories différentes
la voiture électrique le seul autre ace
et la voiture thermique
cette dernière fait l'objet de notre
compétition du jour pour laquelle les
pilotes viennent de toute la france
le club est super sympa donc y retrouver
également l'ambiance avec tous les tous
les potes avec lesquelles roulent en
général au club sur le stand de
préparation entre deux courses les
pilotes aussi mécanicien bichonnent
leurs bolides
j'ai entendu de changer ma batterie
parce que l'âge et roule pour 20 minutes
donc j'ai besoin de changer ma batterie
une passion qui se transmet ici de père
en fils les plus petits entre en piste
au milieu des corans deuxième vers les
voitures et quand j'ai voudra pas faire
ça m'a donné envie de faire
le jeune mathis prometteur a remporté la
compétition dans sa catégorie
prochain rendez vous pour le club ce
samedi 25 mai pour une course d'une
tâche en intérieur ça bouge au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines trois
semaines après ces championnats de
france est ici au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
la 12e édition du trophée des
entreprises sera organisé entre ici et
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines et des entraînements ont
commencé pour être en pleine forme le
jour j un reportage d'oreillons 11
chaque vendredi une vingtaine de
salariés basée sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines se retrouve
sur le parvis du vélodrome nationale
après quelques minutes d'échauffement
c'est parti pour une demi heure de
footing
encadré par un coach sportif le but
c'est d'allier course un pied en même
temps exercices de renforcement
musculaire
un gros point positif surtout pour
l'esprit sportif et l'esprit de l'équipe
parce qu'ils font la cour son équipe
tous ont un même objectif se préparer au
mieux pour le trophée des entreprises
qui aura lieu le 13 juin prochain et
après 45 minutes d'effort très bien ça
permet d'aller plus loin que si j'étais
tout seul du coup pour ça je suis
content c'est sympa de voir les
concurrents les adversaires et aussi de
m'entraîner avec mes coéquipiers pour
renforcer l'esprit d'équipé possible
c'est sympa l'année dernière 600
personnes ont participé à ce raid
multisports plusieurs épreuves attendre
les équipes course à pied course
d'orientation encore relais vtt
si certains participent pour gagner
d'autres on tend tout autre objectif
s'amuser
parmi les épreuves redouté par ses
participantes celle du radeau dans le
cadre de cette préparation saint quentin
en yvelines propose de vous familiariser
avec embarcations et vous donne rendez
vous le mercredi 12 juin de 18h à 19h30
sur l'île de loisirs
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo spécial
championnat de france morgan quels sont
les moments forts qu'il ne faut
absolument pas manquer ce week end
eh bien écoutez je vous invite à venir
soutenir les équipes de la gemme c'est
demain soir donc samedi à 17h30 et
dimanche toute la matinée voilà samedi
soir à partir de 15h30 pourrez aussi
retrouver toutes les équipes de division
nationale une
c'est les meilleures équipes il y aura
des gymnases de l'équipe de france voilà
un très bon moment et un beau spectacle
c'est noté morgan très bon week-end sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or
[Musique]